deux personnages orphelin de l'auteur il
l'attend en vain puis se mettre à tracer
leur propre trajectoire un monde
fantastique inspiré de ionesco un
théâtre du corps mêlant humour et
onirisme servi par un dispositif
scénique novateur l'univers virtuel
immersif comprenez un effet 3d il aura
fallu un an de travail pour élaborer de
ce spectacle écrit comme un film les
ingénieurs avaient besoin et le celui
qui fait de créer les images avaient
besoin que que la chorégraphie très
définis dans l'espace pour qu'il puisse
y avoir une interaction après avec
l'image donc on a fait un peu le chemin
à l'envers on va dire ce décor vivant en
3d a été créé
au fur à mesure pour créer la
chorégraphie au fur à mesure qu'on
retrait scène après scène et après
arrivée sur scène on sait bien sûr
adapté aussi
à l'image à l'espace pour que ce soit
très cohérent par rapport aux
spectateurs de soirées sont proposées
aux tourangeaux à l'espace malraux une
salle particulière pour la compagnie qui
il y a huit ans quasiment jour pour jour
présenté ici son tout premier spectacle
on a l'impression d'avoir déjà nos
repères c'est note l'ofs on connaît déjà
les cours et les recoins non c'est drôle
parce que voilà on a présenté je crois à
peu près tous les spectacles de la
compagnie toutes nos créations ici donc
voilà c'est un public comme koné qui
nous connaît donc moi je trouve que
cette fidélité dans le travail celle
entre les artistes et une salle est en
train public c'est quelque chose de très
important monsieur et madame raid est un
spectacle tout public qui promet une
expérience hors du commun au croisement
de la danse du théâtre des arts de
l'image et le tout sur les rythme
endiablé de la musique électronique